هم اليم صغيري هيا        أشهى طعام
كل وأكبر يا صغيري       هيا هم اليم
مرة سألت الأستاذ أرنب لما لا تلبس نظارة
قال أنا بالخلق مؤدب آكل دون إثارة
ولأني آكل لا أتعب أجرى أسرع من طيارة
والحكمة في الجزر  وبه يقوى النظر
آكله بحب ونهم
هم اليم صغيري هيا        أشهى طعام
كل واكبر يا صغيري       هيا هم اليم
أوقفت زرافة أسألها لم أنت جميلة تبدين
هزت رأسها هزت ذيلها وأجابت بثقة ويقين
الخضر مفيد وشهي وبه أنواع الفيتامين
ما أجمل الخضار هو يجعلنا كبار
ويجعل بشرتنا أنعم
هم اليم صغيري هيا        أشهى طعام
كل واكبر يا صغيري       هيا هم اليم
وسألت الفيل أداعبه لم أنت قوي ومتين
رفع بإعجاب خرطومه وأجاب أمارس تمارين
آكل طبقي لا أتركه أتغذى كالعدائين
ولذا أبدو جميل وذكي ووسيم
ورشيق دوما و سليم